yo sup guys I looks familiar
yes another package too big to fit in
the screen however if I do blow this up
to widescreen you hopefully should be
able to see a lot of it this I believe
is a think geek unboxing but I'm not I'm
not even going to guess I'm just going
to open a package for you and we'll see
as we get into it now you probably know
before that because you read the title
but this is yet another unboxing and
first first impressions video so you
know doing hardware and software guys
here so yeah let's just get right into
this I'm gonna try to just see how
should I pull this out yeah this is the
laptop sleeve although I think it's
funny because the address that I came
from was Wireless Boulevard that's kind
of funny but I here we go there's the
laptop please and I'll post the website
for you guys right now and an annotation
so please this is the name of the
website it's so low you've probably been
to Solo's website before here's just the
shipping information from so low and
here is the solo laptop sleeve I can
spin that around yes this is a 17 inch
laptop bag so basically first
impressions it is it looks pretty good
quality waste we all have to do is take
this off the box here and we can get
right into the first impression I don't
want to scratch the bag but here we go
alright this was kindly sent out to me
by solo so I want to thank solo after
everything they've done it to support
the link to this bag will be in the
description so you guys can check out
the set see if you like it 17 inch
laptop users might like this let's just
go through the airport Shelton swipe it
smells like kind of like leather but not
quite smell it just has that new smell
but anyway yeah so it just barely barely
fits in the Enya
the picture here let's just open up the
front see what's inside all right so we
have a lot of pockets here wow this is a
big bag we got these two pockets right
here if we just pull these back you have
a little diagonal pocket yeah you
definitely smell leather in there I
don't even know where the leather is but
I do smell leather yeah ID card slot so
very cool you have cards left you have
pan holders and but I have a feeling a
lot of it best is going to be found
inside of this package so stuff next up
real quick
you know I'm thinking I'm going to have
to change the camera angles to get the
entire 17 12 top bag in here so let's
just go ahead and switch that angle okay
so I'm back and I I apologize if you're
like hearing things or stuff going on in
the background my windows open and
everything but I'm just going to get
this on video up because this is an
unboxing so what we're going to do is
just pull this back we can see there's
paper in here so I'll take the paper out
and now that's very cool so we have what
looks like a little keychain holder up
here again this is for going mobile with
that 17 inch laptop we got a different
pocket here a cell phone pocket or a PDA
pocket that is good that's very good and
another pocket that looks like a
rectangle shape I could put a charger in
there so let's close that up and it's
all it's all zippered by the way it's
expandable keep going through this close
it up the lappers bit though sorry the
zippers do say solo on them that's cool
now let's just open up the top part of
this container and see what we can find
in there so this is another expandable
port looks like I can fit like a little
cooler in here and this is probably the
main laptop case ah there we go that's a
cool accessory that they've provided if
I can get that to focus that is a sleeve
not a sleeve a shoulder strap so you can
ah I'm just going to open this up here
but this is a shoulder strap for the bag
and it is made of the same material so
that's cool it'll have a shoulder strap
to go with the bag for going mobile so
that's very very convenient what else is
here
little advertisement for solo so um yeah
we'll keep going and yeah this is a
Velcro velcro container the laptop
likely going here at the silicon-silicon
jail whatever that is but yeah the
laptop and the laptop cooler can both
fit in there it just really reminds me
of a messenger bag so again you want to
check this out the link is in the
description and the title is the name of
the product itself so yeah this is a
pretty this is for looking pretty cool
I'll get you guys with a for review
video I do have a target version of this
and I might do a little compare contrast
video you know you got your handle right
here looks like the looks like the via
what do you call it the carrying the
carrying strap will hook onto there and
there and you can just pick it up and
carry it well yeah it's a neat looking
bag it's very professional-looking you
could carry that to anywhere you really
need to do without looking weird or
anything it's great very nicely built so
yeah I'll be getting to you guys with a
for your view video this was just an
unboxing and first impressions I'll see
if there's any pros and cons that are
worth mentioning and I yeah so thanks
for checking out this video hopefully
you watched an HD so you can see all the
very fine details of this Sena
that's it for the solo unboxing so thank
you guys for watching and please
subscribe if you haven't already a lot
more tutorials software hardware like
you